[Music]
Mila Montreal and Canada plays a
leadership role at the intersection of
scientific advances in AI and the governance
necessary to ensure its
ethical and socially
responsible development Mila is proud to have
more than 1,000 student researchers and 100
professors, including 53  chair in AI Canada
if which together form a community
dedicated to scientific excellence and
innovation our teams work
closely with industry
to encourage
Canadian companies to adopt li for example our
applied educational programs have been
offered to more  of 3,500 managers and
technicians from SMEs and large
Canadian organizations in addition to
contributing to the economic benefits for
Canadians, social responsibility
and social good are at the heart of
Mila's values ​​we are determined
that artificial intelligence
benefits citizens at home.  society as a
whole and the planet our
Ia for Humanity team works
tirelessly to illuminate the opportunities
and risks posed by Mila carries
projects dedicated to advancing the
common good for example in terms of
diversity or to cope  to the
climate crisis and establishes
educational programs focused on
ethics in AI our
scientific director Professor Yoshua benju
is very active on the
international scene and meets with
world leaders to ensure that
governments take the
necessary measures to manage  and oversee the
development of this powerful
technology. We firmly believe that
diversity of talent and expertise
is essential to ensure that
biases are limited and to develop
technology that represents us all, which is
why Mila and the other
institutes  of research through the
pan-Canadian AI strategy
have affered 30 programs dedicated to
equity, diversity and inclusion
last year it is a
historic and exciting moment for Mila for
Montreal and for Canada we have
the opportunity and
moral responsibility to play a global leadership role
in this new era of
artificial intelligence